are you ready to go yeah let's go back
to you your favorite podcast you know
what it's called I got my boy Stephen
weeks
Steve's back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and remember just singing - always here
Steve alright so this is part two yeah
part three I don't even know it's a part
of the Lisa part - yeah yeah yeah at the
minimum is part - yeah you know what
before we get started riff from a
Griffin has a great sponsor they just
send em you know sponsor they just sent
me a box of stuff and I want to give one
to Steve thank you
last week I read the letter two episodes
of good to say this for me I wanna read
it
all right that's a letter I got from the
company bootie wipes dear mr. Eric
Griffin hope you enjoyed these bootie
wipes and that they make your upcoming
travels smoother we can't wait to catch
the next episodes of your awesome
podcast family so anyway I'm give you a
B a box of booty wipes from the company
I love Steve I will cuz i buy on baby
wipes at Ralph's yeah I do that
well I buy these baby wipes cuz I like
that there's a certain kind of has a
cucumber smell oh God it kind of smells
like booty smells like a cucumber salad
like aloe vera cucumber no I don't think
so they just have like a you know but I
wouldn't know because I'm not you know
something smelling my own booty so when
you after you go poo yeah so you did you
just yeah you can use it for your hands
cuz I guess so after I go poo poo
I take one wipe and I do the first I do
the first enjoy you do a first pass huh
and then and is this right or wrong so I
wipe and then I look at it well you have
to look you and to make sure that you're
like not something like if it's purple
yeah you want to make sure you're okay
so there's like okay there's like most
of the poo and then I'll grab another
wise right and then because there's that
much on the first one yeah did I get it
all so it's like if you or if you're
rolling it to like a car wash yeah yeah
yeah it's basically you do the first
render rent and then you have to soap it
up then you wax it right yeah so sorry
forgetting the detail about doing well
that's Stevie we be everybody with a
proper booty etiquette so can I do a
commercial proper booty technique well
they're not paying me for commercial
song they just sent me a box of booty
all right well I'll use you want a
commercial you know there you go product
placement place yeah but anyway Steve
Steve leaves here everybody let me the
wonderful Steve least evenly no one no
one calls you Steven doesn't call you
see that's mine no one calls you see
that's my that's my government name okay
Steven Lee even Lee is here
Steven Lee so even Park Lee Park okay
well I brought you here Steve because
you know we I wanted to talk about the
Fantastic Joker movie and they loved it
and the Batman universe right what do
you think of it what do you think of the
new Joker and I wanted to give a shout
out to mommy and Joaquin Phoenix yeah oh
you don't know I wish I did you know
what that's why I like him I wanted that
before I kind of analyze and breakdown
the Joker uh-huh I just realized the
other night cuz I was
in bed thinking about him okay that's
know his performances okay so you're
laying in bed no I just have your
favorite lotion hey it's the same way I
used to think about Eric Stoltz and his
performances okay great actor a pulp
fiction post I appreciate great acting
oh great performances great I look at it
as art like an art form right Daniel
day-lewis yeah he's always fantastic you
know what I'm saying but Joaquin Phoenix
I put in that same category there's
certain actors that I put on a higher
tier right like when Daniel day-lewis
did Abraham Lincoln yeah have you seen
that yeah I mean there's there's I'm
watching where he's like sitting in yeah
yeah yeah I remember watching it going
oh is that one Oscar right there that
yeah that scene it's when actor actually
transform transforms into that person
yeah cuz you know anyone could I mean
not anyone cuz it's a heart it's it's a
it's a thing you have to learn to do I
mean maybe you could be born with it but
there's certain actors where they're
just on that tear yeah so you think that
Joaquin Phoenix gotcha yeah and the
Joker yeah he you know what I realized
when I was thinking about like him and
his performances I was like you know
what he could do anything and I'll
definitely tune in and like watch they
give it a check out yeah I could just
watch him like whatever he remember you
did that documentary pursues that was a
rap thing no strain but um like even it
could be anything and I'm like okay I'm
tuned into anything he does well I only
when I think of him I always think of
what's the one not Braveheart the the
Roman the Roman one you know oh
gladiator yeah he was good I always
think of gladiator won out of him but I
don't think of too much more than that
you know master yeah I let's see I only
saw in her Oh her was good I didn't I
only saw it like briefly like on a plane
that was a good movie yeah but again it
didn't like it wasn't like a masterpiece
right right but I think Joker it's up
there for me and I'll tell you the
reasons why in comparison to what in
comparison like of your favorite movies
of all in comparison cuz I'm gonna give
you context of why I think it holds up
because first of all it's taxi driver it
was real it reminded me of like oh damn
- yeah old-school taxi driver and the
King of Comedy mm-hmm Robert dinner and
it's ironic how Robert De Niro is you
know homage yeah yeah so not only that
is just and then just the way he
dedicated himself to the role like he
actually lost weight so whenever like
whenever someone like actually
physically transforms like like
Christian Bale and The Machinist yeah
something like that or like anything
that Jodi Lewis doesn't always work
though Jared Leto gained a lot of weight
for a role in that movie was terrible
I'm just saying it doesn't always just
gives you physically do something that I
think that's great it shows the
commitment yeah it doesn't mean the
performance is gonna be fantastic the
way this one was yeah Christian Bale
does that as well yeah Chris bales done
that yeah yeah I like that and I just
loved his acting in it yeah I thought
that he made some choices that were just
kind of like out of the box
yeah well that was interesting it was
like I did I like just just like the way
his posture was during certain scenes
like remember like he was standing in
the middle locker room and like he's
like hunched over and you could see the
ribs yeah it's just and just his dancing
and everything - yeah I thought the
movie was a the laughs I'm sorry I
didn't want to cut you off but his
choice of his laugh and I liked how it
was like a medical condition
you're I'm saying yeah yeah yeah so what
do you think I mean well I mean the you
know they obviously played with the lure
of Batman you know they they played with
like the origin story I don't even know
if this was an official origin story
like you know cuz like you know in the
there's a version in the comics where
you know Joker his character falls into
a vat of chemicals and that's what makes
him into the Joker right but this was
more of like this is a you know
condition psychological thing yeah like
delve deep and we turned into this
monster but I thought the movie was
disturbing from the jump like the
opening yeah it was like he's just
looking in the mirror and I felt like
they stayed at that seemed like a little
bit too long right yeah yeah what's he
doing like he was so weird like you're
not doing this you know it was kind of
like you know I loved it because it was
like anyone could relate to like a
tortured soul yes I can not only the
tortured soul but like being the outcast
alienated yeah yeah like a person who
doesn't know how to fit in with Society
stop so the Joker's an insult I'm not
gonna talk about the Intel community
because we did that last time but I
think that in cells can really relate to
that character because of just the
alienation and being an outcast okay
well I didn't know you were that in so
spoke I'm not and PME links to like like
what I need to check do you do to get
those yeah because we men are talking
about you know I was really offended you
know if you decide to talk about this
topic make sure you know well I just I
don't want to get through the day I
don't normally like a lot like
a lot of movies recently but I really
did enjoy this one and I'm like you you
you use this word far too often when you
go see a movie but every time you leave
a movie you like you're like it was a
masterpiece you say that a lot but you
say that a lot about [ __ ] move do i yes
you do
you should might hold up in my defense
all the time I mean you may have said it
like three times yeah exactly just too
many times in every movie can't be a
masterpiece but you know what
do you remember what movies yeah bring
dead that stupid which you said was a
masterpiece that you couldn't even so it
brought that you know why Rock Roger
Eggers he's a new movie coming out
called the lighthouse I think it's out
this week so we should go sad it's his
sec that'll be the one we'll talk about
that we're gonna go see that one and
we're talking with him that's not even
gold up but the witch people it was
another piece it was good okay thank you
it was a good movie it was not a
masterpiece solid okay again solid can I
see it okay so what pulp fiction is a
masterpiece yes
can I say that yeah I agree will you
agree that pulp fiction father is a
masterpiece
you know Goodfellas maybe wow that was
good you know would you say No Country
for Old Men is a masterpiece I don't
remember it hey when's the last time you
saw that well I haven't seen that one in
a while I know one will do Steve we'll
have our masterpiece list that's what
we'll do for our next version you need
at least a month yeah okay that'll be
our movie The Shining is that a
masterpiece haven't seen it in a long
time but it probably is you know all
right you know okay let's get back to
the Joker
okay I'll ah I loved it yeah well I
thought it was a masterpiece this is the
first time I'll say it I thought it was
a masterpiece because of all the
different elements it was good or great
in many different elements of a movie
so like cinematography I mean the
cinematography was just it was just
majestic like everything when he's
dancing
the city the city things even when he
was laying on the ground after he got
beat up that shot that they chose I mean
just it was such great cinematography
and then the next part I thought was the
the acting I thought the acting was
great so that was like it was just above
average
his commitment just his perform on his
performance was great and then you had
the direct is he deserve at least a
Oscar nominee well you probably will get
an Oscar nomination I'm not sure if
that's like you know I don't know who
decides that stuff but you know we live
in weird times right now we're but I
think that the movie itself deserves a
nod in one of these areas you didn't
bring up this is why I like the movie
yeah
I wasn't finished talking about why I
like it Steve no in my defense
and you know what I'm not gonna I just
realize that when I talk it's louder
than I really want to talk so I'm gonna
talk like this now I don't like the
sound of my own voice
well that's why when I was talking about
this earlier like the echo like yeah III
went I'd rather hear me like right now
opposed it when it gets to the editing
program right right and I know I'm going
off-topic but I can't even listen to my
own podcast when I'm yeah when I'm
editing myself I'm like okay enough of
me me
I can't hear me for more than 10 seconds
I'm like okay let's just what you got to
listen to it to figure it out yeah but
that's just my own thing but going back
to the Joker okay I went back I came
back thank y'all I loved
listen
Tarantino does this the correct way I'm
gonna talk about violence the violent
scenes okay dude I love the vibe the way
I thought it wasn't gratuitous I grew
you know I mean it was just enough you
know I liked that I was sorry
it was jarring I liked it was believable
- yeah yeah yeah like I don't want to
give it away any spoilers but you only
[ __ ] the yuppie dudes yeah like messing
with them I thought the way he fought
that the way he battled back in like
yeah shot you know like like the way he
killed those guys and even in his
apartment the way
remember the little guy came in and oh
yeah that point he'd already crossed
he don't know lost over to him I was
covered my point being the way they went
about it was freaking awesome oh I loved
it yeah I thought that like before I saw
it you you you heard you know stories
about like oh the violence and too much
and when I started I was like I don't
think it was to my head it was just
talking about critics yeah I thought I
don't listen to credit I thought it was
just what do you call it um it was just
enough I don't think it was gratuitous
you know so that goes to like you said
that were twice now yeah
what is what is just too much you know
what it's my definition yes the
Webster's Dex you know - it is yeah it
just means that's you you said that
twice now yeah but that's what it means
when it's just like overly overly done
because because the cuz it could be seen
in this way cuz gratuitous it sounds a
lot with the GRA
T right gratitude
yeah that's not that I know I'm just
like I don't know cuz I think you are
confusing me when you first said
gratuitous I'm like okay he's like
giving free of charge
okay uncalled for lacking good reason or
unwarranted okay unwarranted yeah fair
enough so that's you know it just it so
in that in that case like you know he
but again I guess we're like he
what I liked about that seemed like in
the subway was like he shouldn't have
had that gun you know you don't have a
gun with you because then if you have
the gun I know but if you have the gun
if you have to gun you have to use it
you know or you don't necessarily
technically have to is his situation he
needed to use it he just it was the only
thing he could you know I okay okay
you're talking about that particular I'm
talking about that scenario I agree I'm
seeing like on general terms you could
just have it just to ease your mind the
same way I'm you know a person carries a
pocket knife yeah but if you have ones
who really uses a pocket I know baby I
know but Steve if you have a pocket
knife and then for some reason three
people attack you you're now you're now
obligated to use that pocket knife and
then you're gonna use it like if you're
not a professional pocket knife user if
you're not Rambo Rambo which is a damn
good movie first blood was one of my
favorites
first blood I've seen a new Rambo no but
I'm going to you have to go see the new
Rambo I actually really enjoyed the new
okay so she's out to Sylvester still
gratuitous violence unwarranted
unwarranted okay so um okay so we're
talking about knives now that's not a
good comparison because um John Rambo in
first blood I'm talking about first
blood the very first one had a survival
knife yeah that's different than a
pocket knife if you have any knife with
okay so if you have any weapon with you
I thought your specific note if you have
any weapon with rocket Knight if you
have any weapon with you and you were
attacked yeah you're obligated to use
that weapon of course and if you're not
able to use that weapon you might cause
some and people would say that person
deserves it
so there's people that would say that
someone deserves it like like so with no
way what are you referring to now
deserves what are you talking about that
a scenario a scenario where you're
getting jumped yeah of course
okay so what I'm saying is this like
three guys Bhd
let's go back and forth ban [ __ ]
all right if you have a knife okay
you've decided to carry a knife if you
are attacked by people there are some
that would say those people getting
attacked the people attacking deserve
what they get okay so what I'm saying is
if you have that knife you now know that
you're going to attack back in some
cases with lethal force all right okay
so there's that in the movie the guy had
a gun and he was being attacked by these
three guys when he pulls for the gun and
kills you know he kills the first guy
who was attacking him you don't I mean
did that guy deserve that yeah you just
going these things that you don't listen
and then you like you know I want you to
hear me and I want to hear you go the
first man that attacked Joaquin mm-hmm
on the subway deserved it he deserved to
die
well he deserved he's gonna reap he
deserved to die not die but at least he
deserved
okay with this my points there are
repercussions okay all right and the
repercussions worth he died I know but I
was gonna go on to this second and third
guy I don't think he needed to oh bit
excessive
at that point okay so this is okay this
is my whole point that's why your turn
now no no my whole point is if you have
a gun he killed that first guy okay yeah
you have to say to yourself do you think
he deserved to die
he didn't necessarily that's what
happened he died right well he didn't
necessarily know so Sara necessarily
deserve to die and that's why point is
what I'm saying is that's why if you're
gonna carry a gun you have to know that
you might kill someone deserving or not
bad person or not you have a gun you're
gonna end up doing and that's what he
did I have no argument against them yeah
but any but I grew the second guy it was
like okay now he was doing it because
[ __ ] I killed this guy I got a [ __ ]
kill these guys too
the second the second guy was like I
gotta kill this guy cuz he's too close
to me what not that third guy was that's
cold-blooded murder why there's level so
third guy he could have just let him go
to a different car or whatever but he
could have at least shot him in the
kneecap but what was great about the
movie it's because he shot all three of
those guys that when the the little
dwarf guy you really thought he was
gonna kill him like I wasn't sure if he
was gonna let him go or not that was
probably my favorite scene in the movie
not one particular scene but did you
laugh
I laughed on the inside I didn't laugh
when the dwarf couldn't reach the chain
I was terrified because I'm more
self-aware in the movie theater now oh
because of my incident watching the
master with my brothers ride right right
so now you are now I'm a little bit more
like aware of you know but people laugh
during that see yeah but you know that
was a crazy you know but I thought that
was a such a well done scene I loved it
you know she's a well loved I loved the
choices that were made and I love the
way he let him go yeah I loved it but
there was a moment I was like would he
really let him go you know I don't know
you know I know it was just so but
exactly that's why we love Joker because
you don't know what he's this guy's kid
you know he's so so um well let's talk
more about what we liked about the movie
but keep going
um hold up before I forget what's the
word I'm looking for the adjective he's
so unpredictable sorry sorry I
at least get that yeah he was he was
unpredictably very well yeah it is yes
and no you know he was unpredictable you
know because he you know you you yeah
you right it was just so many great
things like you know the fact that he
was like hallucinating about this name
you know that was a element where I was
like oh [ __ ] you know wasn't that crazy
I'm so glad you brought that up yeah
because okay so I brought up taxi driver
mmm-hmm I also brought up King of Comedy
uh-huh but then the third one I want to
bring up and this is all gonna relay
back into Joker uh-huh
is Fight Club was very fight club' yeah
three different yeah it's also very
great movie those are great points great
reference points yes so there was a
little Fight Club going on you know meta
and then like the real I think today I
don't know I don't have a mental illness
I I know people that have mental illness
you're far from it you don't mean so I
know people but I don't know if did they
do mental illness justice you know what
I'm saying
I think yeah I mean because like what
movie gets that in depth as far as I
mean there's like Bob even said carrot
there's like character study I really
this was a character study he really got
in he went Dovan deep and you know the
dude studied this [ __ ] what to find out
like and it also had some serial killer
elements because because what they talk
about with serial killers is they all
hate their mother like this is like a
thing about serial killers all those
[ __ ] shows came out you know you just
get you go deep dive like yeah that's
one of the tell tells about a serial
killer as they hate their mother
you know let's the rich liberal a it to
Joker yeah at the beginning of the movie
he didn't have he didn't have disdain
for his mother he actually brought her
it's not intact all he did I thought he
I didn't I say he hated his mother but
he definitely was like about his mother
you know right I think it wasn't until
he found out with the Wayans yeah that
that the truth about like that situation
as far as oh yeah the relation that he
went
his own Deep Diver resentment really
kicked in yeah but it wasn't it wasn't
even her fault turns out she had a
mental illness you know what I mean okay
the most disturbing I'm sorry for to
know what the most disturbing scene was
when he you could just say it is spoiler
alert guys as a fund at this point but
that was the most disturbing to me but
at that point he was like he realized he
saw the file and everything that
happened to him as a kid and I think he
was like Dan is this why I'm [ __ ] up
but then he just like you know yeah that
was the end of that so I was saying all
those different elements the character
study of it makes it that that was a
masterpiece of filmmaking to just
watching this guy go from like a weird
guy to tipping over to being a
psychopath like he didn't have to be a
psychopath you know what I mean and he
just like went with it
I love it the makeup I loved oh yeah I
loved how he looked
I loved how he walked I loved like you
know that stuff I like the environment
everything about it
now I'm getting this I'm getting
questions about this is his performance
opposed to Heath Ledger's performance
and I don't think it's a fair comparison
because there are two different
approaches
I totally agree with you I was like it I
was gonna get into this later but we can
we can just talk about it now because
like you know that's the two most those
are the two you know what I mean like
distinct Joker performances right yeah
but here's the thing I'll say in favor
of Heath Ledger
it was pg-13
it's a DG 13 movie so he had to there's
just so much he could do that he was
right there on the edge of being just
like you know his he was so committed in
the performance you know I would have
loved to have seen him do rated R No
glad you brought that up but like I look
at both performances I put them in the
same regard I put them in the same
they're both free yeah I don't want to
compare the two I think they were both
phenomenal right but like but like you
say though you know when you people are
comparing them and I just say that you
have to take into account I think the
rated-r pg-13 thing you you I think you
really do have to take that into an
account of course you that is there
certain things you can show during one
the other one well obviously you could
show more violence and yes and the
dialogue will be a little bit more
extreme yes yes yes yes I totally agree
with you I'm trying to like I don't know
why this is doing this like this yeah
I'm gonna make sure my so I didn't
realize I know you like you kind of like
told me that we're gonna do I did this
is a lot about so these gonna be movie
reviews no no we well I wanted to talk
about like like we were gonna get into
this anyway I just wanted to say I just
wanted to finish talking about this
particular job movie that we both liked
it I thought it was a great acting great
cinematography great story great
directing but there are I do have some
problems with it though but there's
there's flight really yeah my first
probably have one but you say I have two
okay my first problem is that he was
trying to take that they were trying to
say that that situation had happened on
the subway sparked this like citywide
you know the rich versus poor Anarchy
the Anarchy was started from that and I
I wanted to see him revel in that a
little more I don't think he really
liked they tried to make reference to it
towards the end that he was like oh this
is all because of me you know right but
I wanted to see that more big reference
more to that develop more yeah in the
middle of the movie you know so that's
my one problem I like seeing like I'll
give you an example like David Koresh or
so any one cult leader or something that
people follow yeah it's kind of like
showing the scene before they like move
to though they create their own
community yeah just even expressing how
bad the city would really
was that this was happening like there
like I well one of the other things I
really liked is that they made Bruce
Wayne's father a [ __ ] okay yeah that
was a new twist I like that I mean I
like I was like oh this is great because
they always portray him as like some the
great guy the savior Verne I know he's a
rich [ __ ] and he's like not taking
care of the sinner so I like that I love
this scene by the way when I walk in
visits their estate okay that's my
second problem oh you didn't like it
no because Batman in this movie Bruce
Wayne yeah is like 10 years old okay
Joaquin Phoenix is like 40 okay
by the time Batman becomes Batman why
can't it be 75 years old
and it's not gonna be it's that gonna be
old Joker do grandpa Joker so that's the
only thing I couldn't get past and I
know the reason why they did that
I'm only implying that I like the
interaction okay okay I could see why
Joker Joker was told you know I just
like the interaction it was great that
was fine but he's too old
okay like if you would have um like if
Batman if Bruce Wayne had been in like
in college and make more sense made more
sense but they wanted to show the the
origins that's a tough decision to make
this is just a one-off movie though it's
a one-off it can't be a sequel because
they will be ridiculous
I mean imagine how much effort that took
to do that kind of acting yeah well I
mean you know look I think that the the
Batman the Heath Ledger you know he was
before he died wasn't he saying that
like it would took a toll on him to be
oh yeah yeah so you know I don't know
I just don't think acting is like a
natural thing so why you see a lot of
actors with like some issues you know
and he really tapped into something on
there but I find him to be a weird guy
anyway anytime you see what King Phoenix
on interviews and stuff he doesn't come
across I could do that you just like it
just a chill dude yeah I'm chillin cats
why he intrigues me so right right
he's weird like that yeah I'm I like
because I'm weird
yeah we do I like weird people yeah I
get it he's weird dude all right so we
talked about the Joker let's talk about
like other Batman and Joker performances
that you think do you want to compare
those in a while though the only ones
are the Nolan one like I haven't like I
forgot like that Michael Keaton was
involved in yes I Danny DeVito is like
that pink you know I like that was so
long oh those were so campy
yeah well I'm so far removed from those
like is it like I haven't seen those in
you brought up you brought up taxi
driver know like the nolan ones are the
only ones i'm like i like a hole closed
to me well if i think back to Jack
Nicholson as the Joker that was probably
the third best Joker maybe again but
only thing about that one is he was old
in that right Jack Nicholson was an
older guy
so like that worked there great actor by
the way but like but what you call it
Michael Keaton was also like a certain
age in that movie too so I don't know I
mean I I never liked Michael Keaton his
back man you know I like Michael Keaton
as an actor yeah I did too but I like to
but that was like close after
Beetlejuice so for me I was like Batman
butyl just can't be Batman
but there's a lot of people that loved
that Batman they loved him as bad so you
got so you got Michael Keaton then there
was uh who else was Batman George
Clooney those were the terrible ones
those were terrible then there was a
Weston one guy he was in Top Gun
now kill Val Kilmer I actually liked Val
Kilmer's Batman but just that one was
weird cuz that was the one with Jim
Carrey as the joe as the Riddler which
was a good Riddler but the movies were
so campy I would like Batman Begins is
the first time that superhero when the
nolan changed the landscape of superhero
i love every single one of those you
know he changed the bane one that was so
stupid oh yeah dude let's go I think
we're gonna go into this now that was
thinking when you said Jim Carrey hmm
I'm like I don't know why I thought of
this one I'm like dude I bet you Jim
Carrey could pull off the Joker as well
now what if that's the role that like
people take now to like win an Oscar you
have to be the Joker
yeah task at hand yeah but I think Jim
could do it yeah I think you could but
it was like so you had him well I just
think though I wish that those
particular actors were in this new realm
of superhero movies by the way just real
quick when I think about Martin Scorsese
trash in like the Avengers movies and
like superhero movies how he's saying
that they're not real movies that's not
real like What did he say let's go to
the well the iPad to find out what
exactly what he said what do you think
of that well I think I don't know I'm
not familiar with the the specific
article you're talking about but I think
that speaking generally about Martin
Scorsese because I respect him as a
director so much that I think that he
has a right to state his opinion on what
it was as far as cinema is concerned
yeah but like he said well that's such a
specific thing to say about a specific
genre of movie but I I don't know I
don't I'm not I'm not too much invested
in stuff like that cuz I don't care what
anyone says even if you're like you know
like the bet the top-notch director or
whatever I'll I'm still gonna watch the
movie you know what I'm saying
I'm just I don't know that's why I try
not to what he clarified his statement
you know yeah go ahead
really says like his does this DES
clarification statement was what has to
be protected is the singular experience
of experience in that picture ideally
with an audience but there's room for so
many others now and so many other ways
there's going to be crossover completely
the value of film that's like a theme
park film for example the Marvel type
pictures where the theaters become
amusement parks that's a different
experience I was saying early it's not
cinema it's something else well so now
so now we're talking about different
it's definitions of what cinema is yeah
cuz but you can't blame Martin Scorsese
because since he has been in the game so
long
he probably and I'm sure Tarantino's the
same way they have a certain idea of
what a movie should be right so when he
cuz because the reason why I'm talking
about this because you said amusement
park and I could see why they would say
that but like my point being is people
are still no but I just I disagree with
the whole concept fundamentally I just
agree with them I disagree with him
completely you know like the Marvel
movies for instance what's his name
Robert Downey jr. is great as Iron Man
like a fantastic actor no no that's a
matter let me finish yeah he makes it
believable he makes it the the effort
that he puts in as an actor is not like
some campy [ __ ] he's actually put
like it actually is like you felt you
felt for him and so just because it's
not some pretentious movie about gangs
so if it's not a gang movie where people
are dying and shooting up stuff you know
then that makes it that makes it that
makes a real cinema I mean I think that
that's like no see we're talking where
he's talking about like more aesthetic I
understand what your savings do well I
know but he's relating to the overall I
understand we were saying about Tony
Stark Iron Man how that's such a gray he
did agree you know but I think like the
overall appeal and vibe of it he thinks
of it as like Disneyland or like an
amusement park it's a difference as far
as what he thinks is cinema and movies
and what other people and but I see both
sides because it's like well not
everyone's Martin Scorsese yeah there's
a family that lives in somewhere in like
Dayton Ohio that's you know for the
weekend they're gonna bring the kids to
go see Avengers whether you like it or
not they're still gonna do that right
and so it's like it's tough man it's
kind of like God would be good analogy
well he I just feel like he's bashing
like movies that are you know popular
movies or just because it's in a series
oh they did that it shouldn't have the
same value why he's made some [ __ ]
movies too it's like so what about so
this is a no-shit movie that you didn't
but he's done some mass you know I don't
wanna yes a masterpiece cuz with him
there's some masterpieces but it's kind
of like this I'll give I don't know if
this is a great example but this I'm
gonna use this I'm gonna use this as an
analogy it's kind of like someone like a
singer-songwriter like out like you're
you know like a Bob Dylan mm-hmm it's
like someone like Bob Dylan like looking
at today like a kpop or a popular like
boy band or something that's popular
right to him that's not music this stuff
that's on the radio right and what I'm
saying but to other people no that's
what's no no and what I and III reject
your analogy why no what why is that
because I'm saying that vengers is like
the Jackson 5 and one of them is Michael
Jackson okay so one of them is a better
actor a performer than most like like
kpop and like that's insulting to the
Avengers like some of those like the
endgame in like some of those movies
there were really great movies so
Scarlett Johansson there's like Janet
Jackson no I'm just saying I'm just
telling you that it's not to say that
that the Avengers is like kpop is saying
that they that there there really is no
any like contemporary like like like
band that's popular on the radio not
kpop yeah but even some of these bands
that are popular on the radio it doesn't
mean that they're not music or they're
not see that's what Martin Scorsese is
stating because going back to Bob Dylan
it's like the writing the song writing
aspect of it is not in the same vein as
the [ __ ] that everyone that for like the
average family enjoy I know but in what
I'm saying is
easy to cuz look at DC couldn't do it
right like it's not easy to do ten years
of movies to lead up to this big event
it's not easy to do it should be I think
this should be valued for what it was
look I understand both sides you know it
looks like I don't want to say one is
right one is wrong but I could see I try
to see it from both sides and look I'm
just you whether someone says something
about one thing like rotten tomato
whatever cuz that's a critique right
kind of that's critique of something
that I want to see yeah he's crazy genre
I'm still gonna watch it you don't want
to make my own critique but I've
sometimes I think don't want people like
that critique those type of movies yeah
they're trying to say like like don't go
why is everybody spending money and
going and watching that entertaining
film come watch my boring ass
three-and-a-half hour film where no
we're getting killed but listen listen
you know me at least for me I'm gonna
watch both right me too
I'm gonna watch all of it right you know
like I think the one thing we haven't
even discussed look it's entertainment
right if I want to see someone fly
through the air laser beams Connie eyes
and I want to see crazy I don't know
it's entertaining dude in the same
industry gonna watch it what I'm saying
though is in the same way that like
gangster violence is like entertaining
to people because that's his wheelhouse
you know it's always about like you
don't mean so that's all so to me it's
equivalent to superhero [ __ ] right in
its commoners like I'm sure like Stanley
Kubrick would say the same [ __ ] yeah
you're I'm saying like these types of
directors cuz they're so oh gee and
they're so like yeah so about their
aesthetic in like yeah you have to
remember that they make a lot of [ __ ]
movies too so much I'm still gonna watch
it I totally agree
I know it's so tough in today's from the
which you see the crappy ones that was a
damn good do please don't talk down on
that that was a good movie so you liked
the you liked the Nolan Batman's I did I
when I look back on them now they were
marred with like too much tragedy and
stuff like the best one to me is still
gonna be the first one because it
reinvented it reinvented to superhero
genre and that was a really brilliant
origin story of Batman I really enjoyed
that but like the second one was ruined
because obviously unfortunately
tragically Heath Ledger died and the
fourth act to the movie with that whole
two-face thing I thought all that was
dumb I just thought I just needed that
it ruined the movie to me right and then
the third one was just an utter just
utter nonsense like a group of people
are not gonna be able to take over a
city for six months like I'm sorry I
couldn't suspend my disbelief I realize
about you you you go so in-depth as far
as you said you like to move detail I
know but like going back to me like I
understand why you would say that but
dude like Tom Hardy's performance man I
mean what you couldn't understand made
fun of than anything else now I don't
care I still loved it I like the fact
that even like with the voice the the
voice that that choice mommy Darth Vader
you know you know the mask and we can
understand Darth Vader I didn't hate the
movie but it to me it wasn't a good
ending to that Batman at least give it a
P I would I would have loved that Batman
today yeah it was a C+ dude at the end
of the movie there's a bomb that's gonna
blow up all of Gotham it says like one
minute on the timer yeah Batman gets in
his little plane and he flies it take
it's a four-minute scene
yeah but the poll point is just what it
took for him to get there yet is just
look it just became nonsense yeah
towards the end of the movie and I was
like this isn't a good ending to this
series look I mean I you know I actually
you know I actually do like discussing
movies with you specifically because we
don't agree on anything
disagree right now yeah that's not true
did you what did you think of like this
new like what did you think of Ben
Affleck as Batman you know what but I
haven't see that's one I haven't seen in
decades I haven't seen that decades it
hasn't been out of that well I haven't
seen in years sorry
many many many the one that was Batman
vs Superman that movie it wasn't a very
good movie I haven't oh you gotta watch
that I would say watch it for the simple
fact that there's a great Batman fight
scene in that movie you ever played a
video game dude Arkham Knight or Batman
one of the ones I was addicted to it
it's also one where there's a side thing
the Riddler yeah yeah yeah dude ice okay
check the powers looking for the river
the riddles okay check me check me this
dude but listen how you brought that up
no but listen are we going in a video no
but we can if you want see focus the UH
in this movie he has a Batman fight that
is like the video game okay like he uses
the disrupter he uses the boomerang he
uses the grappling hook it's just like
it that fight was like them to me the
most spectacular Batman but he's just
looking up on YouTube yeah yeah yeah the
most spectacular Batman fight look I
like I said that that one particular I
think it was Arkham Asylum I don't know
what the name of it was but I spent hour
I spent you know how we played it you
know
having to play hours of destiny yeah I
played hours about hours up all night
dude what I loved about that game it was
a so open world like you could be
working on one mission and then like
yeah it goes oh there's this other
mission and I never actually I never
finished the game like I never got every
single ring you know I think I did 90%
of those oh and then they had those new
what do you call it like those extra
DLCs I think I don't think I got into
that oh yeah they had some new missions
because like you can't just have a
spectacular game like that and then just
end it Duke honest with you my mind is
starting to wander for this I don't know
my mind is I'm stressed out right now
I just mind is wandering I'm spacing out
what are you thinking about right now
Steve cuz we'll end with that I don't
know I'm hungry I gotta get to you some
food guys no no no I want to talk let's
do it let's try to do 20 more minutes
then we got no weed Steve please you
can't you can't be like imagine you
having sex with your girl okay and life
is a horrible example your brother let's
say you have a sex right and then like
in the middle of it she goes you know
I'm kind of I'm kind of spacing out
right now there you go okay my bad we
can go 20 more minutes would you want to
continue that after 20 minutes yeah you
probably would I wanna talk about tell
us what you want to remain being to end
this so the remaining 20 minutes okay I
want to talk about because we both have
channels I was doing this we always talk
about this Steve but tell me let's see
where are we now since we last talked
about our channels how you doing okay
well as far as well you gotta ask more
specific questions those Wars like
subscribers content
you feel I'm invest how I'm feeling
monster ships what do you want to talk
about how are you feeling about your
channel to this point you want the on
honest answer no lie to us of course I
want the honest answer you know what I
realize that I don't think we'll ever be
happy so that's my honest you're not
happy doing Stevie we yeah cuz what I
realize cuz you know I don't like to
compare how could I compare to who to
every name whatever popular YouTube
channels out there because I like to
look at other like what are they doing
what I'm what am I not doing what makes
their things successful right what am i
lacking what choices do I need to make
in order for me to get more subscribers
or more like eyeballs on my videos it
you know what I'm saying yeah and I
realized I just can't it's hard to wrap
my head around it I guess cuz so you're
not having fun doing it you just burned
out on podcasting not only that no
because it doesn't even that's just one
aspect of it we talked about this in the
car yeah you're doing solo episodes
you're doing you know other you're doing
Q&A I got my game yeah we're doing
different things yeah you doing
different things you can do it on the
street you got the boxing thing done by
the unboxing and all that and let we
opened up bootie wipes on my podcast but
I just realized we have to cuz if we're
if we're resting on our laurels and like
this is all we did right right let's say
every week what you did well I did we we
interview a do a person a man or a woman
at least one hour and that's it and then
you do your comedy sets I go writing in
my notebook doing other things whatever
it may be we can't survive you know yeah
I'm you know what I read it's this is
this is great we're talking about this
because I'll tell you I'll be honest you
like Stevie on the street you right yeah
if it wasn't for Stevie on the street II
which
to check that out on my YouTube channel
it's me doing Street interviews that
helps my other views yeah I noticed that
when I upload that okay let's say I
upload when do you up love Monday's but
do the audio on Saturday okay I do
Wednesday audio Friday so when you when
I upload my regular just this yeah
interview the guest I noticed that when
I upload the other content like Stevie
on the street II it picks up slack for
the thing that I they interview I did on
Wednesday yeah well you're still doing
those weird interviews though what do
you mean you know like in the you know
you find somebody from the back of a
hip-hop club that just stumbles out
since I'm so self-critical analyze stuff
too much maybe I want to get the the
people on TV or a huge gift but they
don't they don't read my messages what
I'm trying to say is there's only so
much reach that I could do because I've
tried to reach out like who knows the
Natalie Portman's the the Becks you
really think natalie portman is gonna
cut you a little no like that would be
fit just I just won't see any Portman
walk through that jungle to the back of
that like death that's not gonna happen
okay this is the main point before I
lose my main point huh there's only so
much reach that I have right now if
there was some kind of podcast agency
like the same way you guys have agents
for your theater if there was something
this would be great if there was an
agency where I didn't have to worry
about guests and there was their job to
find the talent yeah you'd be having a
great time yeah but Steve you get a
publicist you know
you know publicist company girl a hi
ever on this podcast I had this many
people I'd love your client no no that
takes money no it does it you got listen
you never listen that's your problem
I'm listening right now I say you hit up
the publicist to go if you want your
clients to come on my podcast you know
not you get a publicist and I continue
then what what's then they're gonna be
like then they're gonna funnel their get
their their clients to your podcasts but
won't because I don't know that's great
we're talking about this cuz I don't
really know how that world works
yeah I don't know I know what a
publicist does but what I'm trying to
say is I thought that in order for them
to do that they're gonna be like well
you know their daily fee is $1,500 no I
don't know this stuff publicists are the
ones they hit you up and go hey my
client would like to come on your
podcast do you do that cap no publicist
hit me up all the time like hey my like
that's how I got like three guests on
because of their figure out you've been
on television shows I'm not on the same
tier as you might know it Steve you have
more subscribers than I do
you're missing the point okay you Montel
you go on you don't say the name right
it's it's Montez you know what I mean
you're Montez come on I'm sorry you're
Montez people knows more than that Jesus
you've been on t my point you've been on
television no it's about the podcast
reach man it doesn't matter who you are
oh you're missing the point the reason
why publishers are contacting you is
because of who you are they're not gonna
contact this is I'm sure that that's
part of it and that's why I'm saying to
you you reach out to the publicist and
go yo here's my you know I this is that
I have this many numbers I'd love to get
some of your clients on okay so after
when we go eat talk about this I loved
it oh this might help someone to this is
exactly what would she talk about cuz
there's someone out here that's like
they're like somewhere in like Michigan
to wanting to start a podcast and that
this will be good good information I
guess so so but even even agency contact
play even look like if you know like
there's a particular actor you want
you're not gonna hit up Natalie Portman
you're gonna try to hit up Natalie
Portman's manager or agent and be like
hey and that's my question how do you
find like she's IMDB to [ __ ] you know
there might be so you do you do remember
you might be able to come on your
podcast if you just reach out not him
yeah just [ __ ] never listens did
you hear what I just said okay yeah
you'll fly from London to Los Angeles my
be in LA if you look at his schedule
he's in LA listen I hear you're coming
to LA you're right let me get you on my
podcast I'm a huge fan you never know
Steve okay okay you know so we're gonna
put this out Lee universe yeah we're
putting it out there that we're both
Steve and I are still trying to improve
our podcast we're gonna keep coming
together talking about movies we're
gonna go start watching movies together
so we can come on and just get you guys
caught up on how we feel about movies
but overall we both enjoyed the Joker
you said we don't agree and we both love
to the Joker masterpiece because I
wanted to stay on this content topic I
see what you're doing I realize I just
caught you in the app I just caught your
hand in the cookie jar
I know what you're doing we're still
talking about this honest answer from
you okay do you enjoy doing all of this
Oh
does it bring you happiness can I give
you an analogy this is like doing
stand-up okay so I like it I like when
I'm there and I'm on stage and I'm
interacting with the crowd the stuff I
don't like travel packing doing morning
press you know those things I hate going
through the airport going through the
security those are all those things the
things you don't like are those things
you're talking about
it's like editing scheduling guests you
know working all that [ __ ] out all the
time that's that's needed to like edit
and all that right that's
the fucked-up part but you know what the
fun part is sitting with my boy Stevie
Wiebe and just talking about stuff right
you know getting like the positive
feedback from the fans you know when
people are like you know they're
clamoring for like hey when's another
episode coming out or I really enjoyed
what you said anytime you get any kind
of positive affirmation from from the
fans you know it's just like you go oh
this is why I'm doing it you know so it
does bring me some happiness with you I
just have it all compartmentalized in my
head you know what I mean how do you do
that
it's just something I do you lump
everything in the same not only that is
I have a problem with staying in the
results like like when it went like when
it's not doing good numbers right like I
wallow on that I'm like oh you know like
it make it like ruins my day I'm like Oh
what do I do wrong or why are more
people watching this well I think you
should have an overall picture of like
you're just putting out content weekly
some people are gonna it's gonna
resonate with some people sometimes and
it's not other times and you just keep
doing you're not gonna stop like it's
not like we're not doing this because
okay if I don't get this many views I'm
gonna quit that's not why we're doing it
there's no way there's growth you know I
mean like family-owned this is gonna be
episode like 53 that's a lot yeah but
you don't you're in the hundreds no
you're not too far behind I'm a hundred
and twenty okay why ma'am far behind and
if you keep doing it I'm always gonna be
that far behind you so how many when are
you gonna be happy when you have 8
million subscribers when a win is when
are you guys with you that there is an
element of being in an entertainment
business that you're never happy so what
I'm trying to say to you is let's just
enjoy the ride that's why we're coming
together that's why we do this together
because this is more fun you're right
that having some dude that we don't even
know so that's what I like to do this
more often all right you want and we
just keep doing this and we're just
gonna enjoy the ride so that's what
we're gonna come we're gonna bring the
content to the fans that they want to
hear from us they love us talking about
movies so we'll continue to talk about
movies and video games are you still
open for
you and possibly Bob to do our thing
yeah but last time you talked to your
brother
yeah you know I mean no no I did talk to
him a few weeks ago why I want to have
to come today I've been trying to hit
him up for a week about coming today and
he wouldn't get back to me so I'm over
it you don't I mean I'm just I'm just
completely over it you know I mean I
could get your mom before I can get you
know she was great on the market really
sit down with Bob I've done it so many
times and be calm
and maybe write in a notepad you're
Chokin well like what bothers you talk
to him and this is what you need to do
make sure he doesn't have his iPad or
his phone see because when you're
talking to him he likes playing that
game so you saying he's rude
no he's just distracted with with
gadgets so at the time to a chair and
make him listen you need his attention
yep I tried okay or you need to do this
you are you going to call me sore
tonight yeah I'm gonna see him tonight
oh he's gone okay this is what you need
to do when what time's your said but ten
what times his I don't know but he'll be
there tonight I'll see you when you see
him don't it's all in the approach don't
go hey man like don't don't do any of
that you know just be like hey good
seeing you Bob it's not gonna work with
him what do you mean you think you can
well this other way it's not working
what you getting mad is not gonna change
well Paige you know what this guy that
after every approach I've tried he's got
me to the point where I'm gonna be like
I'm not gonna try anything
have you tried have you cried oh my god
that's gonna work with him it might
handle him I just consider it can he be
a considerate friend
that's all I'm [ __ ] asking for it's
the approach though he
because listen I'm sure he's done that
to other of your the comedian friends
you didn't answer my call
like he's heard that yeah see he's so
used to it I know it's the Pavlov he's
so used to that that no it's almost like
you might have to do like a form of
shock therapy no do you know what I'm
saying were you shocked are we gonna be
a punch to the gut no no no don't don't
please don't punch you but if you like
shock them like with a stick why should
bring a Taser to the comedy store
I don't know I don't know it has to be
the idea of like a tasing or shock
therapy where you don't actually do it
you know it has to be in a verbal well
you know what the next time we talk I'll
keep you up to date about what happened
yeah what happened with this know my
space exhale I deal in Dickstein that
you guys need to go watch that episode
he's a funny DT wait he worked at SpaceX
he worked at NASA he wants to go to Mars
I had a great episode with any kind of
flu no there's no flu it's all and then
we got our booty wipe Steve I always I'm
talking to you we always have a good
time we're just both hungry frustrated
what do you want where you want to go
eat this is Korean barbecue place I
think it's one of those places where you
get to meet you know me it's like $19 a
person it's right down the street
oh that's a good price I know it's on
you today I got well I go I will but let
me go to the ATM
I'm only teasing you this is DV we be
everybody again so we can I start
plugging in a second so recap we both
like the Joker we weren't gonna talk
about more Batman stuff but he hasn't
seen it that often we talked about you
know what we gonna do with our podcasts
and we're gonna do moving forward we're
gonna go watch that lighthouse movie and
we're gonna talk about that
I'll still attempt to get Bobby to come
on but that [ __ ] hard to track
down and we could keep doing that and
then you could find Steve on his channel
I have all of his information below as
usual but go ahead Steve
alright so mark if you haven't checked
out my podcast go to WWE youtube.com
slash DB we beat all with double e's I
have a website now called Stevie we be
show.com WWE you don't have to say the W
W okay sorry Stevie we be show.com my
Instagram's
Instagram /qu ang okay this
informational people Oh hold up I'm
still gonna say it and then I have a
Bandcamp Stevie we be overly Bandcamp
calm I'm work can I can i plug I'm
working do you think I'm working on a
new album it's called oh really it's
it's cuz my you know our Father just my
dad just passed right so I wrote as i
already i did one song and i figured I
owe
I'm gonna make it projects like
surrounding him oh well cuz it's helping
me as far as therapeutically oh yeah
talk to you soon you know what how about
next time next time I come let's get
like talk about it we will um but yeah
so that I'm working on a project about
that I don't know when it's gonna be on
my band campus dude I'm still waiting
I'll do whatever you want with you man
like I'll if you want to do a podcast
how about we will talk we'll talk it
dinner yeah we're gonna target dinner
you know I love you you know
report back to you guys I got so much
love ends you're like my brother yeah I
know you're like but I get back to you
[Laughter]
alright guys this has been referent with
Griffin this is my boy Steve Steven Lee
you can find all this information below
HDB we be a case TV baby
my Korean name oh yeah I never knew that
we don't know that
Kwan I take offense to what you just did
I know let's say like that's my Korean
name and you know why are you laughing
because I will tell you why
unbeliev Koreans are so funny that they
know their names are so ridiculous
did they give themselves American
Americans equal no one's gonna be John
Steven Bob cool cool well what'd they
just like you just like Steven just call
me Steven all right well Steven Kuan Yew
did we at least make an hour I want to
make sure you got an hour Steve I think
we got more than okay how do I know it's
an hour it's more than I want to make
sure you got an hours we don't want to
give you an hour
I know it's we can monetize and do what
you need to do is it an hour yes love
you guys see you next week